Oh
the needs of our planet were greater
than she could supply so we sent men
beyond the reaches of our atmosphere but
the open space gave way to an insurgency
we will eradicate the authority obviou
the settlement defense front built an
army how well is just beginning a war
machine there's time one day they'll
come it is not enough to break free try
to take our homeland this is rated 6
coach Roger six Detroit Oh and the ADA's
guns they appear to be tracking our
fleet
captain's dead went down with his ship
so who has the Conn Gator I believe you
do sir
today's attack was not limited to Geneva
said death launched a concurrent strike
on the moon gateway port Tigris and
retribution are the only operable ships
we have
lieutenant Reyes you are now the acting
captain for attribution
assault with me always ground a soul
captain spices on the bridge not this
captain about today
let's get these bastards
right listen tell us anymore
kill them
let's go get him hello thank should be a
blast
the pilot of this ship it's my job to
make sure that we get if you like that
kind of choice that you have no place
then you come on it's time to raise the
black flag and start cutting throats
with this
pre-order now and get access to the
multiplayer beta